good morning Hank it's Tuesday it's
question Tuesday the day that I answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
let's get right to it
what's the cheesiest joke you know you
know what kind of cheese can perform
miracles Jesus of Nazareth who the F is
wait wait I got a better one what
happened after the French cheese factory
exploded there was debris everywhere got
any new books coming I'm trying
payant if yours did you name Isaac that
because his eyes are sick no
unfortunately I'm not that funny except
when it comes to cheese jokes I named
Isaac after the guy in the Hebrew Bible
who also went blind how excited are you
that the tibias DVD comes out tomorrow
good news friend tomorrow is now today
and I am very excited because at last
people can see my brilliant acting in
the extended cut will you ever appear in
a movie of your books I have I had a
cameo in The Fault in Our Stars movie
but it got cut because my screen
presence was too powerful they fell like
they wouldn't be able to pay attention
to Hazel's love affair with Augustus
because they would be distracted by the
cameras love affair with me any news
about the Looking for Alaska or Paper
Towns movie so know much about Looking
for Alaska but Paper Towns looks like it
is really really going to happen like
they hired a director that brilliant
Jake Schreier who made robot and Frank
Chris Green play by the guys who wrote
if yours is amazing my friend NAT Wolff
is gonna play Q and supposedly it's
gonna come out on July 31st so it might
actually happen if you could change
anything about your books what would it
be the word deadpan appears like 12
times and Looking for Alaska which in
retrospect is probably 11 times too many
how do I pass ap chemistry crash course
might help who's your favorite Beatle
what color would you be if you could be
any color
I promise these were right next to each
other in my timeline John Green our
oranges named after orange or is Orange
named after oranges the name of the
fruit preceded the name of the color by
at least 200 years
bananas are pineapple I guess we've
reached the fruit portion of question
Tuesday bananas will there be a
nerdfighter meetup soon their location
specific nerdfighter groups all around
the world link in the doobly-doo there
are lots and lots of gatherings I've
always had a good time at them check it
out while you love the metaphors why
would argue that most humans love
metaphors because so much human thinking
is symbolic like we imagine a meningitis
headache as a vise grip in our head and
if we can imagine like particularly
original or compelling metaphors it can
help people to imagine what we're
feeling so good metaphors make my
experiences more real to you and yours
more real to me which is kind of what
language is supposed to do right can you
make a metaphor using the word slay and
now this is on my area of expertise but
I'm pretty sure the colloquial use of
the word slay is all
ready metaphoric I mean I don't think
that new Taylor Swift song actually
killed you but we say that it's laid us
because the experience of it was so
awesome that now we are metaphorically
dead nothing it's a great metaphor but
it is a metaphor pizza or Ansel Elgort
Ansel Elgort on pizza Ansel Elgort on
pizza is not an acceptable answer then
I'm gonna go with Ansel Elgort slathered
in pizza hey review Hanks album it's
Hank Green's best album to date the
perfect strangers bring a punk rock
energy to Hanks quick-witted and lyric
driven songwriting I give it 5 out of 5
stars it's actually Henry's second
favorite album behind only the Phineas
and Ferb Star Wars album aren't you an
egg's supposed to do a punishment well I
owe one Hank what's my punishment how
did you decide on baby names you just
stole our grandparents names how many
boys are in one direction what is this a
quiz show there's Harry and Niall and
Liam Zayn for what none none there are
no boys in one direction they are all
adults hey how many books can you
balance on your head seven but not for
long I tell you Sony's really cute hey
Henry a stranger on the internet says
the you're cute how do I get my
three-year-old eat anything other than
pvj pizza and macaroni you can get your
three-year-old to eat three different
foods are you a wizard what color
unnecessary you are your socks many code
happy socks our signed posters really
signed or just digitally when I say that
something is signed I mean that I signed
it like with my hand and a pen writing
font:arial thoughts on wheezy waiters
latest video Oh favorite HP book and
movie or comma eight what's your
favorite dinosaur
Stegosaurus because when I was a kid
paleontologists thought that it had two
brains a head brain and a butt brain and
there was nothing in the world funnier
to me than the idea of a butt brain I
have a question mmm that's not a
question Maureen that's a statement and
so is this Hank I'll see you on Friday